Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bar and it's the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
May 28th, 2012. How's it going?
Wow, I'm happy. Memorial Day.
Um, thanks to all the troops, you know,
that's what you're supposed to do today,
right?
Anybody and you still
recovering from the cookout,
your cookout for the troops,
your 12 pack to the head
for the fucking heroes.
I don't give a shit what a holiday is.
I don't give a fuck what is for.
Eventually enough years goes by and it's
just an excuse to become a tub of shit
and drink a 12 pack, you know, and
get all your feelings off your chest.
You know,
all that shit that you've been hammering
about the person that you with.
You know, a few weeks ago somebody
was asking me, Ah, you know,
they wanted to break up with somebody and
I was saying, listen, you gotta listen.
You know,
the person who has it down how to
do the breakup was minivan men,
podcasts,
own celebrity star Al Madrigal.
But if you don't have
time to email Al Madrigal
just listened to ll cool j a big old,
but
I don't know why. I never really listened
to him when I was growing up. You know,
Mama said knock you out. Oh,
did she? Is that what she said?
Ll Cool J I don't care. You
know, I just wasn't into it.
And his deodorant and his armpits when
he was jamming with those white guys.
I just, I never got into it. But lately,
lately I dunno. I Dunno what
happened. I just just come
onto my youtube shit.
I don't know what it is,
but I was listening to some
of his stuff. Oh, I know why.
Yesterday I was trying to remember like,
what was that song he used to have that
I'm the type of guy and you're the type
of guy, he put Paprika,
what the fuck was that?
And then I listened to it and I kind of
liked it, but I hated that. Oh we, oh,
part of it really annoyed me and my co
that's why I never downloaded this shit.
But then on the side,
they had a ll cool j big old,
but you know, I play drums at Michael.
Let me hear what this tracks sounds like.
Can I put it on?
And he basically teaches you hide
a breakup with a girl in that song,
but that rap or that, uh, that rhyme,
whatever, however you supposed to say it,
he breaks it down and just
in fucking 11 seconds,
he sits his girls down.
He's basically hanging out and like some
sunglass hut or some shit and some girl
comes in with an insane ass and
he does what every guy does.
He stares at and he thinks, I want to fuck
that. But Oh shit, I have a girlfriend.
So what does he do? Does he
sneak around on earth? No.
He goes home and he sits
her down. He says, listen,
I met this girl named Tina.
Okay. Tina's got a big old,
but I know that I said I'd
be true really whiteness up.
But Tina got a big old butt. So
I'm leaving you. It's, I mean,
that's just fucking air tight.
You can't fuck with that.
He was 100% I don't know.
She could get mad.
I think that I think women's show expect
guys to be lion weasely pieces of shit
that if you actually hit him
with that level of honesty,
I think they would just be stunned.
Just like the chicken, the video.
Like I didn't think that
that was bad acting.
I think that they would absolutely be
stunned if you just came home and said,
listen,
I met this girl.
I know that I said it'd be faithful to
you, but she's better looking than you,
so I'm breaking up with you.
Okay.
What is the comeback?
There's nothing that'd be like if
your girl came home and said, listen,
I know we're together, but this guy,
you know, I met him at the mall,
is deck is twice the size of yours
and he's got a better car. So, uh,
it's kind of a no brainer.
Amada, what are you going to do?
What are you gonna do with your little
dick in your fucking Domino's pizza?
It's over. You just got to fucking be
like, you know, you only go around once.
So, uh, yeah, I, I, I get it.
So anyway, so if you don't
have time to email Al Madrigal,
which you should,
which you should just listen
to a ll cool j big old bud.
You got to see his face. He
goes, so I'm leaving you. It's,
it's, I don't, can't explain it.
It's way meaner than it has to be.
That's what it makes it funny.
Cause there's a way to read that where
you're kind of letting them down easily,
you know, but he didn't,
he just did it like, yeah,
this is how it works.
So they,
you go look at that on a holiday as you
shaken off your fucking keystone lights
that you drank for the troops,
you know,
you're fucking bong hits for the men
and women in the Marine Corps that you
took. Right? Flag Day's
coming up. Everybody.
Well we respect and honor
all the flags of the world.
Come on down and gets your
Busch lite for Fuck Ed.
$12 a fucking case.
Uh,
what the fuck would happen?
What would the world be like if
there was no way to get fucked up?
If you couldn't get high,
couldn't get drunk.
Jesus. How long would marriages last
then? They'd probably be even shorter.
Would they just be rage?
Just sitting around fucking stone sober?
Eight and strawberry shortcake
could be horrific. Um, anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast. It
is the end of May. Everybody. All right.
How many days are in May?
30 days had that timber and
stone is April and November.
All the rest have a bunch of other
dates except for February. Yeah.
Go Fuck yourself with your song.
Um,
she got 30 31 fuck. What is it?
April has 30 June has 30 maze.
31 I got the little thing.
I can click right here. I'll
have a computer. I don't
need to think. All right,
it has,
why is it in September?
Oh, for Christ sake, do I have to
click another button? It has 31 days.
All right,
so you had till have you guys have until
Thursday midnight to make something of
May, 2012 all right. Are you
on a fucking relationship?
You don't want to be in,
do you want to be in this relationship?
in June?
Why don't you celebrate the end of
May by getting out of your fucking
relationship and sitting down
and basically just go
with the ll cool j vibe.
Hold her hand and just go
straight up honesty and then what?
What's she gonna do? What's he gonna
do? They're going to flip the fuck out,
but the the die has been
cast to ship is set sail.
The ball is already rolling. The
Sun is setting, the rain has fallen.
Whatever the fuck you want to call it.
It's out there. Just put it out there.
Let him scream and yell and in your head.
As much as it sucks,
you're going to be like,
okay, I did it. I did it.
Now I just got to sit here
and get yelled at. And uh,
how long can somebody really yell
before they lose their voice and hour,
90 minutes and an hour and a half.
I'm going to be in the car listening to
ll cool j driving away from that thing.
I didn't want to be in. All right. Now
I know I talk about this shit a lot,
but I think a lot of people
are in situations like this
and they don't know how
to sit. Somebody dumb it
just say, so I'm leaving you.
You know, if I was ll cool
j and I stopped, you know,
selling tickets and all that type of shit,
that would be a side
business that I would have.
I would take that little fucking rhyme
that he had and I would custom do it for
everybody in their life and just, and then
people could just write you all right,
I need to charge. You charge them 100
bucks and he would write you a, you know,
four bars.
It all rhymes and you just get out exactly
what you say it,
you know,
just be like you eat with your mouth
open. I know I said that. That'd be true.
But to eat with your mouth open so
I'm leaving you just get right to you.
Just get right down to it.
The mom is a fucking con.
I know. I said that I'd be true. What,
she's fucking always coming over here and
some of the rhymes with and I, you got,
you got the idea right? Jesus Christ.
What do I have to be yellow? Um,
hang on a second. What the fuck just
happened? Did I knock this out? All right,
10 minutes in. Look at that. That was
an easy 10. It was a fucking easy 10.
I actually, uh, actually bought a,
I bought a new grill. I didn't get
to grill. You know what I bought?
I bought that fucking egg thing. Big
Ceramic was like a giant fucking avocado,
which sucks is I can't even talk about
the shit that I bought cause I feel like
now it feels like it's a
commercial on this side. Um,
they're not paying me to advertise.
So what?
So what I feel now you can't talk
about them and see what happens.
It's a catch 22.
Okay.
Speaking of looking like a giant avocado,
how bout those Boston Celtics,
what up Philly? How, what'd you take?
Did you really think that that
was going to happen again?
That you were going to go into Boston
for a game? Seven on the fucking PLA k.
Okay.
And that and that, that, that wasn't
going to happen. I almost would park.
Hey butter at that point,
if I ever made that joke,
you guys should have just fucking
just unsubscribe. Unsubscribe.
Is that how you say it?
Um, Celtic speech, Philly.
I actually watched a most of the game
and then I had to go do my gig over at
flappers.
Um,
so I had to listen to the rest on a,
on the radio as I went over there,
I got to tell you stuff that,
you know,
I'm not expecting the Celtics to win the
championship. I know we're old, you know,
but, uh, the officiating
in the fucking NBA,
I don't think in any other sport.
I swear to God,
do the reps just dictate the
fucking pace and all that.
And I know that I've had a fucking Tampon
in my ass about this for a long time,
but it's ridiculous. Paul,
let me ask you a question.
What in the ever in any game
ever forget about a game.
Seven of an NBA playoff to
go to the conference finals.
Let's just say a regular season game
in the middle of fucking December.
Does Coby Bryan ever get called for a,
does he ever fall out on a fucking charge?
Is that call ever going to be made against
that guy? I'm going to go with never.
Right? Paul Pierce got
five files ticky tack fall.
They fall the guy out on a fucking charge.
It's UN fucking believable.
And just three days before,
watch,
hope Holby I watched Colby fucking
hack a guy across both forearms,
but that would have been his third foul
in the second quarter and they would've
had to sit the guy. And what did
they do? They have a meeting.
The reps have a meeting and they give
it to some bumps standing next to them.
It's just fucking,
it's you to tell me the difference
between the NBA officiating in the
officiating and fucking wrestling.
Okay. If you can do that, then
Jesus Christ. Sorry, did I
just lose you guys on that one?
Why don't you set the fucking recorder
where it's supposed to be there,
right down on the floor.
It's just bring everything down here.
There we go, Bill. Seriously, if
you can do that, I will fucking, uh,
I will go to your town
and I will do karaoke. Um,
and I'll sing whatever
song you want me to sing.
I'll do that ll cool j
song and I'll wind it up.
I know that I said that I
would be true. Um, that's what,
that's what kills me about the NBA.
Okay.
I fucking ever really been watching
it because of the hangover and the
devastation of seeing the Bruins getting
knocked out and I got into it again.
It's just like basketball is a fucking
phenomenal game. It's a pure game,
you know, fucking ball
in a hoop, loving it.
If those fucking striped cuts would just
get out of the way and stop taking out
there fucking frustration that there's
some 23 year old kid who's getting more
pussy and it's worth millions of more
dollars than you and your fucking
footlocker outfit. So now you got to
go around and just fucking Dick to you.
I have power.
I'm going to do what I want to do.
I don't know if it's that shit or if it's
fucking David Stern in their rare with
the Bluetooth, whatever, whatever. So Hey,
New Jersey's own, Paul Versey,
he's been talking a lot of trash,
you know, talking about Oklahoma
City, you know, it's a WHO's,
that's who he's picking. And I
actually picked the spurs, you know,
cause my whole theory that the spurs play,
they play basketball,
the way your dad fights,
you know,
and I think that that was evident
and last night's game, you know,
Oklahoma came out all fucking,
you know,
all young full of piss and vinegar running
up and down the court or what do they
do that they just started jogged
after him. I, I keep running,
keep folks like that. And
that movie colors that, that,
that street joke with a papa
bowl in the, in the, in his son,
the son,
both
father and son bull standing on the hill
and they're looking down at a bunch of
cows and the sun goes, hey, let's run down
the hill and go fuck one of those cows.
And the dad goes, now let's walk
down and fuck them all. All right,
that's the spurs.
Let's walk down,
pick and roll and fuck them all.
That's what they're going to do all
the way to another NBA championship and
they're still not going to get respect
because they play in a city that nobody
cares about. Okay. Mexicans don't
even care about San Antonio.
They don't.
All right.
That's just a little stop off that they
have when they crossed the border before
they go to like fucking, I dunno, l
pass off. All right. It was a bad,
that was a bad example. El
Paso, I should've said a winter,
were legal immigrants
usually end up Denver.
Come right up through Albuquerque,
through Santa Fe, you know,
run past Columbine and they go right
into Denver, don't they? What does that,
is that the 35 north
or zen out the 35 goes to Austin.
This how much fucking road tribe,
road drive and road traveling.
I'd done it goes to 10
is the eight, then there's the 10
and there's a 40 and there's this 70,
then there's the 80, then there's
the 90. That's going east, west.
Those are evens odds go north,
south.
Ah Fuck.
I can't fucking remember anymore.
I have gives a shit anyways.
So what do you guys think? Can the
Celtics lived through another round?
Can they beat a, I like how they act
like, because Chris Bosch is out of it.
Like they don't still have Lebron James
and uh, that guy with the little mouth.
What's that?
Dwayne Wade. What does with his
fish lips? I don't understand.
He looked like a fucking tuna
that can dunk. Um, all right.
What the fuck am I right now? I know
I gotta I gotta do some advertising.
I'm sorry. People I'm
doing like, you know,
like one of these days I'm
actually going to, Nah, we'll get,
I'm not even gonna lie to you.
I was gonna say, you know,
one of these days I'm going to get this
thing into a studio and you know there's
going to be the guy,
the the fucking Baba booey guy who
comes in or the fucking this guy.
This is not happening. All right. It
isn't, this is what it is. All right?
It's just like ACDC his first album.
Okay.
Do you think that they were
going to do something else? Now?
This is what we're doing.
Three chords kick in the cunt
and a guitar solo and that's it.
Go Fuck yourself with done
until the next one comes out.
That's what I'm doing with this. All
right. I don't have time. Yes, I do.
I have. I have the time or I'm
lazy. All right, well fuck you.
You put shit off and your life's don't
ya? All right, here's one for you,
the man. Great. Everybody and
I just received my first man.
Great. They just sent me a free one. Um,
this father's day, they're there.
There's only one. Perfect. Yeah.
If you guys all grilled
this weekend on you,
a little Hibachi is with those anorexic
little grates that you have and all the
grease drips down and light shoe egg
mcmuffin on fire. Isn't that annoying?
You know, cause that's one of the things
that you really, you get judged as a guy,
you know what I mean? What your woman
looks like, what kind of car you drive,
and then your skills on the grill.
Okay. That's how you're judged.
And I'm sure that this will be made fun
of some day on a show like the office.
They will somehow try and
uh, just, they'll show a
guy who's good on the grill,
right? And then somehow they say,
but you know, underneath he has,
he has an underlying insecurity,
right?
Because no one could just be the
fucking man anymore. I'm the man. Great.
Everybody,
this is the deal.
It's a grill enhancement system.
You don't have to go buy a new grill.
Do you already have a grill? Are you
nodding your head? Yes. All right.
Once you like to fucking
put a supercharger on it,
that's what the man great is.
All right. Oh, the next line.
What does a man great us man grates
are 100% made in America. Cast iron,
grilling greats. All right. See given
American's jobs and you're grilling.
Good Lord. All we need is a stripper
in here and written an American flag.
This is, this is you have
a kid rock video. Um,
these heavy duty grilling greats deliver
exactly what you need to achieve the
steakhouse flavor you've been looking for.
Now,
what they're really saying there is,
are you tired of your friends making fun
of you and your lame ass cube steaks is
the guy. This is going to teach you how
to grill correctly. Um, or at least,
you know what I'm trying to say here with
man grades, patented design, chicken,
steak or veggies for all the
trader Joe People, veggies.
We'll have never tasted so good. No
more flip flare ups. No more dry meat.
Guaranteed the guarantee it.
So basically they're giving you something
that will make it impossible for you
to mess up, mess it up. Which
means as you're growing,
you can be looking over your shoulder,
talking trash to your friends about
how good your burgers are going to be.
All right.
Take advantage of their $20 Monday morning
podcast special today by clicking on
the man great banner@billbird.com.
All you do is you go to [inaudible]
dot com you click on the podcast page,
you look over to the right Ra,
you look over to the right,
you click on the man great banner and as
a bonus every bill bird.com or to comes
with a heavy duty man, great grilling
brush to clean it up with. All right,
they're made in America.
There are a hundred percent cast iron.
You'll get steak house quality
grilling in your backyard.
20 bucks off because of my spine,
my podcast and your listener.
Just go to the man,
great banner on the podcast page at
[inaudible] dot com there you go.
Get some for your father.
You know,
does your dad grill cause he does probably
fucked for this country to the last
generation of real men. Um, all right,
let's get back to the podcast.
Where the hell is it? All right,
let's get back to the
stuff here. Um, you know,
lately I've been asking,
I've been asking some of the
ladies to write in and uh, finally,
I haven't even read this yet, but
this already seems like gold. This is,
this is the,
the
on the subject line of this email it says,
I think the guy I'm dating is a pussy.
Hello Bill.
I am a 21 year old student.
I began listening to your podcast recently
and I heard you complaining about how
women have not written in on awhile and
being a woman myself decided to do so
and ask you for advice.
Well, God bless you. Uh,
I live at home with my mom and go to
college. I recently found a very nice guy.
Uh, they were college
and was really into them,
but then I started
suspecting something strange.
I started suspecting that
maybe he was a pussy.
At first I thought it was pretty harmless,
but then one night we had a house
party and everyone was pretty drunk.
And a friend of mine who I haven't seen
in a while was there and when everyone
was way, way, way past drunk,
she tried to get into a fight with me
and eventually pushed me down the wall,
then stole my iPhone and he
was there and did nothing.
Jesus Christ.
I was so scared that I called
my ex to come get me any did.
Okay.
Wow.
Uh,
you think you're dating a pussy?
I mean that right there g and he just
stood there and let this other guy who
used to hook up with you come
in riding in on his white horse.
Anyways, my ex was more of a
man than the guy was dating now,
even though the guy I'm dating was drunk,
I felt like he should have protected
me or done something, anything.
He did nothing.
And later he even confessed to me that
he was scared of my drunk friend and even
scared of me. What the fuck? Right.
Even though he says this
will never happen again.
I have enough knowledge to know that
people do do not usually change like that.
You know? That's a really wise that
you're really wise for your age at 21,
if you, if you're already not buying
into the, I'm going to change.
That's a, you're, you're wise
beyond your years. You know,
they say that you're basically,
your psychological makeup is
done by the time you three.
So if you see some
little toddler standing,
there was somebody is taking his blocks,
that kid's going to be a pussy
anyways, so should I be upset or give him
another chance? Is this a deal breaker?
Is there no way to change a
guy from a pussy to a real man?
Should I just break things
off with him and if so,
should I remain friends with him?
Thanks, Bill. I hope you read this. Uh,
I love you and Nia. Oh,
that's nice. Um, all right.
This is the deal.
Okay.
Uh,
you asking a question?
Is there no way to change a
guy from a pussy to a real man?
Yeah,
no,
I don't
think,
I think that that happens.
I think it happens way more in movies
where somebody has a life changing moment.
Uh,
and then they just decide I'm
not gonna take shit anymore.
But even then,
that just begins the journey of not
being a pussy. You don't just say,
I'm not going to be a posting and Bam,
you're not a pussy anymore. You have,
you got to work your way up.
It's like if you were a hundred pounds
overweight and you like this, I'm done.
I'm not eating fucking ice cream anymore.
The next day you don't have a six pack,
you know, it takes a fucking
year or something. You
really got to turn it around.
So, um, I dunno,
what are you looking for in a guy?
I mean,
I think the fact that you're
writing me and you're saying,
I think the guy I'm dating as a pussy,
I mean that,
that actually hurts me on some level
just because I insert myself into this
story and the person updating would be
calling me a pussy or it could it be the
ex, I guess. I don't know. This isn't
about me. This is about you come up,
you'll stop being selfish. Alright.
Um, I think you've totally,
Ross lost respect for this guy. And if
you don't respect the person you're with,
eventually you're going to
blow somebody else. You know,
if you don't break up with this guy,
that's what I'm predicting.
If you don't break up with this guy,
you just going to cheat
on him just to facilitate
getting out of the
relationship because uh,
yeah,
you know, to get to that ll cool j
moment, we can just be fucking honest.
But I don't think you'll like that was
something about you knowing that people
don't change at your age and the fact that
you like, you know, this guy's a pussy,
he's not sticking up for me.
And the fact that he didn't stick up for
you and then you took charge and say,
well, I'm going to fucking
call somebody who will,
I mean, technically you should have fucked
your ex boyfriend that night and he,
and he shouldn't have been mad.
He should have been like any,
he probably wouldn't have been because
he's a pussy. I ain't no, I understand.
I mean, you know, when you needed
a big swinging Dick, I mean,
God knows it wasn't me. So, uh, yeah.
Um, I think if you don't break up with
this guy, you're actually fighting nature.
All right?
And
you guys are wired to,
to,
I know you guys aren't wired to
have kids with pussies. You know
what I mean? You want a strong sun,
right? You don't know, you know what
that Pussy Dna and your kid, right?
All that's going to kill you.
Imagine that you have a kid with this
guy and you want this kid to be like a,
like your ex boyfriend and it comes down
and it's like this fucking little wormy
worm guy. Ah, that'd be awful.
Walking down the aisle to marry
this guy with dead sheepish.
And usually these years,
you know what dad,
you want this guy to be the man standing
down there and a white Tuxedo like
fucking Roger Moore James
Bond. I think I, uh, look,
I don't know if this just
happened and you're really upset.
So, uh, you know, and like,
and in three days you're not going to
care and you're going to go back to having
a picnic with this guy
because for all I know,
your ex who came coming back,
maybe you broke up with him
because he cheated on you.
Maybe he was too much of a guy,
if you know what I mean.
So then you said, well,
all right, I'm going to,
maybe I'm this next time I'm dating a
nice guy. He's now, he dated a nice guy.
The thing about is sometimes
you date a nice guy.
They can be so nice that they're
pussies. Alright, and look, I'm not,
I'm not sitting there acting like,
you know,
if I'm out with my girl in
some fucking 200 pounds,
300 pounds jacked fucking 25 year old
comes up and starts doing shit that I'm
going to start swinging because I'm not,
I'm not,
I'm not getting my fucking head
kicked in just for the fuck of it. No.
You know what I mean? I mean,
it's not like just, you know,
straight across the board as a guy,
you have to fucking go and get
yet God damn head kicked in.
But this was a fucking woman.
This was a lady. I mean he, Jesus,
it is a weird situation
in defense of him where,
how do you get the fucking iPhone back?
You start wrestling with her and now
you're kind of fucking throwing a girl
around so you're looking at that possible
assault charge cause God knows that's
how the world worked. Works
right now, your honor.
I was trying to steal a phone and he,
this guy is salted me and you're
gonna be sitting there going,
she was stealing a phone and they're
not gonna be able to get past your,
you're a guy and she's a girl.
But um,
yeah,
he should have just,
he should've just held there by the back
of her pants so she couldn't leave and
just stayed out of reach of her swinging.
That's what you do. If you're in that
situation as a guy, he just reached out,
you grabbed by the back of their pants
and you just start running in a circle
until cops get there. So they can't swing
at you. That running backwards. I mean,
I don't know what you,
you get.
You got to fucking do something
and he didn't do anything.
That's the big thing that if you told him,
honestly,
if you told me that this was some giant
guy who could kick the shit out of him,
uh,
I wouldn't say that the guy's a pussy.
You know what I mean?
I mean, what is the point of
going in and getting a concussion?
Getting your tooth driven up
through your fucking nose.
The guys still gonna leave
with your phone. You know,
let's set old Richard
Pryor. Bit Macho, man.
I'll take that knife and stick it up
your ass macho man. It's like, no,
you're going to get the shit kicked out
of you. But this was a woman. All right.
Pill for fuck sakes. Quit. You have
God damn rambling. Wrap it up. Um,
I think you know what you want
to do when you should do it. Um,
you are dating a pussy.
The fact that when he was sober,
he said that he was scared
of her and a view. Uh,
he seems like he's a
little for limped and uh,
I just can't imagine
there's going to be a stereotype,
but a guy like that actually putting it
on you in the bedroom. I really don't.
He probably stares at you and the I, am
I hurting you? Is Everything okay? God,
you're so beautiful. I
mean, come on. Alright.
Flip her over and wash your face and
the pillows. I'm always, she says in ps,
don't worry.
Uh,
that con I used to call a
friend who pushed me and
took my phone is no longer in
my life. She gets your phone back.
Well, what happened with you guys?
Now wait a minute.
What can I hear the followup here?
There's so many different ways that this
could be gone. Was that like a girl?
Like when you thought that maybe you
were a swing in another way and all of a
sudden you broke up with her
and, uh, uh, probably not.
It's just my own red shoe diary
kind of fucking thing. So anyways,
um, what are we 30 minutes in and
the Monday morning podcast? Um,
I gotta I gotta give a little shout
out here to our flappers comedy club in
Burbank, California. This city
that Johnny Carson made famous. Um,
I had a fucking unbelievably
great time this weekend.
I did four shows out there Friday,
Saturday night.
It's the perfect size club.
They couldn't have been more friendly.
They'll all,
the shows were packed.
I was working out my new hour and um,
it was great.
I was working with a Chelsea
Peretti Sacramento zone,
Chelsea Peretti.
She was Hella funny as they say up there.
Um,
yeah,
she was fucking great.
She's sang some ridiculous line
about Michael Bolton backstage,
like just fucking around. And I said
to her, you got to do that on stage.
You got to do that on stage, right? So
most people go, oh, I can't do the youth.
The youth came up with it
and the big keep looking do,
she went up and she did it and closed
with it and it was just one of those,
one of those weekends.
It just, I don't know,
you'd have to be a comedian to understand
how much that like gets you going to
be like,
all right,
I'm going to go up and go try some shit
if she's just going to go fucking sink
some fucked up in line about
Michael Bolton, what? I'm
going to go up there and,
and pussy out of my jokes, my, the
new things that I want to try. So, um,
I was psyched.
I feel like I already got,
I have a solid 25 minutes towards
my new hour where I can actually,
you know,
run my mouth and not do anything on the
special that's coming up because that's
basically the game you do.
You take the special the second it's done.
You then have from whenever
you finish taping too,
when the new one comes out to somehow
come up with an hour of shit that you can
say to a crowd and they won't
demand their money back. So I
have until October and I figure, I feel
like I'm already halfway there, you know,
this time next week I'm actually going
to go out with a buddy of mine. Uh,
you know, I never wrote a motorcycle. My
life is going to teach me how to do it.
I know what you guys are thinking.
Ah,
motorcycle fucking just go by the
coffin with and I'm not a dirt bikes.
Just gonna ride it.
Fucking dirt bike.
Just cause I want to learn how to fucking
ride one. Do you know what I mean?
Just for that, uh,
macgyver moment. This too.
There's a couple things I
want to learn how to do.
I want to fucking learn how to ride a
motorcycle and maybe fly a helicopter just
so I have my,
you know,
just in case if I'm ever in some
Jason Bourne kind of situation.
Okay.
You ever think about that
shit was great about action.
Fucking heroes is I don't give
a fuck what vehicle it is.
I don't care if it can fly.
If it's on the water,
if it's a fucking dump truck,
if it's a God damn tank,
it's just a fucking hovercraft.
Those sons of bitches,
not only did they have time to be
trained in every form of martial arts,
swords, weaponry, guns, anything.
They know how all that works and they
can drive every fucking vehicle known to
man. You know, you got to do
that. You got to, as a guy,
you got to make your or a woman,
right as a girl.
Remember that when he used to spell it,
G R R l because you guys
weren't taking no mas.
You got to make that fucking your,
your action hero list. You know,
you're Jason Bourne list.
Have you ever seen an action movie where
the fucking guy jumps into some vehicle,
a plane or anything? It's like I,
I just, uh, how does this work?
Does anybody know how to drive a
fucking helicopter, fly it or whatever?
I want to be able to do that shit.
You know
what's his face?
Tom Cruise.
Tom Cruise has a pilot's license.
He can ride a motorcycle.
Remember top gun when he
was fucking riding with it
without his helmet on, right.
He can ride a,
you can drive a sports car.
I wanted at the helicopter though.
That's probably the wildcard.
Everybody's got that. It's like
a great pitcher. He's got his,
he's got his four pitches or whatever,
but not everybody has the cut fastball.
I think the helicopter is
the cut fastball for a,
maybe it's a knuckle ball for an
action hero, whatever, whatever.
I never learned how to ride a motorcycle
because my parents would not allow it.
They just wouldn't allow it. And uh,
you know, the fuck was I going to do,
I didn't have the money to buy one.
I wanted to get one,
which required them. I was like,
can you buy me this? Still like no.
And if we could afford it, we wouldn't.
And I was like, why not? They're like,
cause you're gonna fucking die.
All right.
And this is knowing as you are, as a
child. We don't want that to happen.
So no, we're not. We're
not getting you that.
And then I remember I got old enough and
I was going to buy this motorcycle came
out, it was called the Honda
rebel and it was only 1200 bucks.
This was the 80s.
And I still remember the commercial,
you something like a look at my
watch. He was not 51. So I called up,
my girls said let's have some fun and we
road riding on a rebel [inaudible] get
this fucking bike, something
like that. Right. And um,
I was going to buy it and the girl
I was seeing at the time said,
if you buy that, you might as
well buy the coffin to go with it.
And I don't know,
I talked to a couple other people
and people work in emergency rooms.
They call people who ride motorcycles.
They just call him organ donors.
And uh, and I was under
the impression of, yeah,
but what if you got really good
at riding a bike? You know,
people suck it riding bikes.
Maybe if you've got really good at it.
And I basically, eventually, probably
somebody told me, it's like, listen,
stupid.
It doesn't matter how good you are.
If somebody sucks it driving a car,
they're in a fucking car.
You're in a motorcycle.
That's it. You know,
there's no fender benders as they say
on those things. So I was just like,
all right, you know what? That's
probably a good idea. Oh, fucking action.
Heroes can also ride a horse.
It's just nothing. Can't,
there's nothing they can fit,
can't fucking do and climb up the side
of a building. So what you gotta do,
you gotta get a chin up bar and then
you got to start knocking down all these
modes of transportation because that's,
that's as big a part of fucking
Armageddon. As you know,
growing your own food and
having your own water supply,
you have to be able to drive
every mode of transportation.
I guaran fucking tee you. If you go
on Youtube, there's gonna be a video.
I've never looked this up,
but how to drive a tank,
I bet somewhere on the Internet and
if the, uh, somewhere on the Internet,
I bet that there's a video that will
teach you how to do that shit. Um,
so anyways,
what the hell was I talking about?
I just totally lost my God damn
train of thought. Um, oh yeah.
So I'm going to be a off to,
I know what I'm talking about coming
up with this new hour of material.
So how I do it day sees how I do it is um,
I obviously I throw out all my other shit,
man.
I only go back to the old
hour if I have to. Um,
and I just keep talking new shit.
I take all rules of hack.
I throw him out the
window. I will, I will.
And right down to a Michael Jackson
impression, if I could do it,
I would do it on stage. I
wouldn't give a fuck. And I just,
just to be saying something new
that'll just get me thinking that way.
And then in my personal life,
I go out and I try and do some shit that
I never did before because I know God
damn well, I'm going to make an ass
of myself trying to ride that bike.
I'll stall it out. I'll do a face
plant, I'll do something fucking stupid.
Um,
or whatever.
I don't know.
Maybe even that fucking Shit I just said
there about the fucking action heroes
so they can drive some, something will
come out of it. So that is my, uh,
that is what I'm going to
be working on coming up.
And I got a bunch of actually
standup gigs he gets,
starts to get crazy again in,
um,
in June I'm going to be at
the San Jose Improv. Uh,
Chelsea Peretti is on that one also.
I had to give her that one.
It's so close to her hometown
in Sacramento. All her
peeps are gonna come down,
be Hella excited. Um, that's
on June 15th and 16th.
And then I'm doing the aunt and,
and on the 17th,
I'm at the Chicago theater and
that's a Vince Vaughn show,
Vince Vaughn, wild west show. It's
going to be me. Obviously Vince Vaughn,
Steve Byrne, I gotta get you guys in that
lineup. That's going to be insane. And,
uh,
the Chicago theaters to shit,
I actually got to work at
one time previously when I
was working with the Great
Jimmy Norton on his tour, uh,
the antisocial tour, it was me,
Norton a tell in brewer that
was such an unbelievable show.
And the Bruins won the Stanley
Cup that night. So, um,
this is my triumphant return
to the Chicago Theater.
That's going to be Sunday,
June 17th and all right,
so all you mustachioed, uh,
stereotypical Chicago people bring fucking
6,000 of your closest friends down to
that Gig and Ontario Improv,
the inland empire, June
29th, 30th and July 1st.
And then the next Gig I got after that
is Hampton beach and in New Hampshire on
July 14th in Newport, Rhode Island
of doing the Newport yachting center,
which sounds really, like I said, snooty,
but it's a tent that they put up in the
parking lot in Newport, Rhode Island, uh,
July 15th. And that's actually
one of my favorite gigs. Um,
cause I get to go back and see all kinds
of friends and family and that's it.
And by then I'm guaranteeing
you by that July 15th,
I'm going to have my 45 fucking
minutes down. That's my goal.
By July 15th to have a new 45
minutes and then I can coast through,
you know, August and September. Get that
next 15 and then my special comes out.
Right.
And hopefully everybody likes it.
Then they come out to see me and
he's was like, oh fuck. We show him.
He's got a whole new fucking hour.
And that is how you do it. Um, all right,
dilemma bill.
Would you rather lose your driver's
driver's license forever or spend the rest
of your life as a Vegan?
Oh man,
that is a great one.
And I obviously can't cheat on the Diet.
Ah,
what a hell of a dilemma
drive around is a grumpy,
skinny Douche for the rest of my life.
No, no, no, no. Wait. Yeah. Wait, what'd
you write? I just got lost in that.
Lose your driver's license forever or
spend the rest of you have license. Oh,
I'd have to walk around
is a meat eating jackass.
Spend the rest of my life as a Vegan.
I F I'd have to be a Vegan.
I'd have to be a Vegan. What am I going
to pick? I just sit around eating Burgers,
walking around the block,
asking people to drive me places.
I wonder if you could
get used to that though.
I lost my license for drinking
and driving a long time ago,
and that was back when you only lost
it for 45 days on a first offense.
And they didn't count the first two weeks
while I was waiting to get arraigned.
Um,
so it was probably more like 45.
I probably lost it for,
I don't think it was two weeks either.
I lost if like 50 something days.
And I remember towards the end of it,
I almost,
I forgot what it was like to drive
just after that amount of time.
You know what I, if I lost my driver's
license forever, I would just live.
I would live in New York City.
That's what I would do,
man. You know, I'd be like one of
those fucking people, you know,
when you live in New York, Jesus
Christ, New York City, man, I,
you know what the smartest thing I
ever did. I left New York City at 39.
That was the smartest thing I ever did.
New York City is such a city
for young people, you know,
I know I've said to ship before, but like
if you, this is thing, I really feel it,
you got to live there at some point
you life, it's fucking awesome.
You have to live there, but don't stay
there too long. You stay there too long.
That's just something happens. You
become a gore of phobic. You know,
you have some unhealthy
relationship with a fucking animal.
And I'm not saying beastiality, but
like, you know, instead of having a kid,
you have like a cat and all you do is
sit around bitching that there's no
fucking good restaurants in your
neighborhood and it just, it just,
you get all hunched over you, you start
looking like you have osteoporosis,
even if you don't this, that, that
city is for young people. And, uh,
go there and have a good time.
And then you got to get out.
Don't hang there too
long because you end up,
it's like Matthew mcconaughey
in dazed and confused.
You just hanging around and uh,
it's, it's not a good thing. Um, oh,
and speaking of which,
I bought the New Jersey Devils,
the New Jersey devils, the La Kings.
Who Do you like? Who Do you like?
And the Rangers lose the Rangers lose my
condolences to all rangers fans and my
condolences to the world's most famous
arena slash food court. Once again,
another year goes by. No
NBA title, no Stanley Cup.
Yeah.
But for some reason it's the world's most
famous arena because of music cause of
Frankie Sinatra because the led
Zepplin because of Muhammad Ali,
not because of the rangers or the next.
Okay.
And I know that's a bitter pill for you,
New York sports fans to swallow.
And that's exactly why I'm handing
it to you on a nice fucking pillow.
Swallow it because it's all you.
Um,
Celtics by the way, are still in it going
for their 18th NBA world championship,
all championships.
One in the NBA,
in the National Basketball Association
as opposed to that other team out west
that counts that be a title.
We want an NBA title before
there was even an NPA.
Um, anyways, by the way, I've
got to give the rangers props.
Don't arrange your fans.
Everybody stole your let's go rangers.
Everybody stole that
from you guys in 1994.
You guys were the only guys doing and it
became fucking iconic and now everybody
does it. Okay. You know, let's go bro
ends. No one ever did that. It was,
here we go, Bro. Edge. There we go,
Bob. Bob. That's what the fuck it was.
Now I, people go, let's go.
Bro Wins and it bugs me. Um,
I actually looked up the history
of, uh, the beat La Chan and uh,
cause some jackass was trying to be like,
oh shit,
you fucking a DCF Francisco giants fan.
You should say that to the did back in
the [inaudible] go fuck yourself. No,
they did all right.
According to my fucking Internet research,
uh,
the history of the beat La Chant was
actually when the 70 sixers beat the
Celtics in game seven in 1982 and they
were going and we hated the fucking
Lakers. That's how much we
hated the Lakers to sell.
The 70 sixers beat us in
our own goddamn building.
We knew it was over and the
fans chanted beat La. Actually,
they chanted it to the 70 sixers.
All right?
That's how much we fucking hated La.
You know, we weren't going, fuck you.
76 is Yada, Yada, Yada. All that bullshit.
We were just like, all right, you beat us.
You know, as much as we fucking
hate that, we hate the Lakers more.
And then the beat La chant was born.
All right.
And if that isn't a fucking phenomenal
story, I don't know what is.
And I got to tell you something
I hated the 76 is back then.
But when I look back and I remember
those teams, I fuck, I love him now.
Maurice Cheeks, Andrew,
Bobby Jones, Dr Jay.
Oh. And then when they brought in
Moses Malone, it was just phenomenal.
And I love their uniforms back then.
I don't know why they just
don't go back to those.
I don't know why every fucking uniform
has to be so Goddamn discoed up.
I just don't get it. They were
just simple back then. I Dunno.
Although I gotta say I liked
the new Atlanta Hawks uniforms.
I like those better though.
Then once they had back in the day
during Dominique's they were, uh,
they were definitely, uh, I dunno what
the fuck was going on with that. Um,
all right.
Please beat the dead horse bill.
You've received this email
a million times. All right.
Can you please beat the
dead horse and make,
make it clear one more time.
Okay.
That she should not be wasting
any more time with him anymore.
Sincerely pronouns.
What?
I don't even get that.
I know you're trashing me.
Can you please beat the dead horse
and make it clear one more time?
That she should not be wasting
any more time with him anymore.
I didn't know what the fuck that is.
You got me.
You got me surf or Ma'am or whatever,
you beat me.
I don't even know what that means.
A weird signals from a sort
of a creepy friends. Hey Bill.
Uh,
I'm a girl that has a lot of guy friends.
I'd say about 70% of my friends are
guys a half our gay half aren't,
you know what?
I can't fucking stand.
I Hate Wa women who have gay
friends and they refer to them all.
That's my gay, he's my gay. I fucking, ah,
those women are the fucking worst.
And then there's stupid gay friend
comes around Cock blocking Ya, you know,
with his Sassy fucking bullshit coming
in and out. That's when he just like,
why aren't the two you go
fucking finger blast each other.
No, it's really, it's
really fucking annoying.
It's really annoying. It's, and then
I always feel like the gay guy is gay,
ended up his act and he just
like acting extra gay, uh,
like sit-com gay, not like
real life gay. And it's,
the whole fucking thing is just
annoying. So anyways, she goes, uh,
and lately I've been noticing a lot of
my male friends have started staring at
me.
It's a little weird because I've known
them for a while and no one ever looked
at me twice,
but over the last two months,
I keep catching them looking
particularly my friends, so-and-so.
All right, well what's going on
with you? Did you hit the gym?
Were you late developing?
Are you dressing differently?
Um, uh, so and so is my age and sword
and sort of kind has a girlfriend,
but not really. Oh Jesus.
Are you that kind of girl?
Nia went off on back in the day.
Girl has all guy friends. Uh,
anyways, she just turned 15.
Oh wait a minute. Now you wonder
age. I don't want to read this.
Okay.
She just turned 15 and he's determined
to wait around for two years until she's
legal in the eyes of the state we live
in to officially date and get what their
sense all they've done is
kiss creepy, I think. Yes. Uh,
I would say definitely yes.
Okay.
You sitting there floating around, just
going, let me tell you something, man.
The second model law allows me to take
my dick out. I'm going to do with it.
That's fucking creepy.
Anyways,
now even though he's allegedly
in love with this child,
he gets super flirty
with me when we hang up.
Even going so far as the cop feels,
make jokes about us hooking up
and give me long hugs. Yeah.
Stay away from this guy.
This guy's a creep. She goes,
I'm friends with this dude. But this whole
situation weirds me out as it should.
I'm not sure if he really wants to stay
with his girlfriend or try to get or try
his hand at dating someone
age appropriate.
Okay.
But there's a fucking ton of mixed signals
going on here and any outside insight
would be awesome. Thanks in advance. Um,
I think you got to go
with your gut on this one.
I think the reason why you're getting
creeped out is because this guy's creepy.
That's fucking creepy.
Okay.
All right. A 22 year old guy
with the 15 that's Chris Hansen.
Can you wait?
Can you kiss a girl who's 15 at 22?
What are you doing? You're in the prime
of your life. There's plenty of fucking,
uh,
yeah,
you're 22 years old. That's
it. You're a fucking rock star.
There's a zillion women that you could
get with. Yeah. This guy is a creep.
He's beyond a fucking creep. I remember
when I was 22 with an 18 year old girl,
felt like a child at that point. It was
just weird like that. That's a huge jump.
This is still living at home.
You know,
you're of legal drinking age.
You go on a titty bars.
You getting arrested for
fucking drinking and driving.
You flunked out of college. I mean you're
eons away from where they were at 18.
That's how I felt.
Okay.
Um, I remember as a, as a senior in
college, like freshman seem like,
like children. That's fucking weird.
Yeah. I would stay away from that guy.
And um,
okay.
And as far as guys looking at you,
it sounds like you're a,
you have to turn it into a swan.
They acuity pie.
So why don't you go get a guy
you deserve, stay away from, uh,
the future sex offender. You
know, because you're just gonna
have to testify in his trial because
you're friends that he's actually a good
guy rather than a bad guy
that is beyond fucked up.
A 22 year old guy making out with a
15 year old girl is beyond fucked up.
That's beyond fucked up. All right? Yeah.
Like to the point, I wish I
didn't even read it. They're like,
ruins takes all the fucking comedy out
of this shit. All right, 53 minutes in.
What do we gotta do here? Uh,
Hey Hubbard, some advertising.
That's a nice set upon
little Chris Hansen story.
And now let me tell you some stuff
you got to buy. Um, all right.
What do we got here? stamps.com
everybody. You know what?
I've been talking about it forever.
I've been using it now for like, what?
Since like February shipping
all of my DVDs in my bbds,
in my own apartment. I'm
dead serious, man. I got it.
I got to scale. I still haven't bought
my little, uh, I'm a postman hat yet.
You know, little visor, like, is he going
to ship a package or when the u s open,
nobody knows. Um, look, this few
things that are bigger waste of time,
they go into the post
office when something like
stamps.com exist. All right?
You can basically bring the
post office into your house.
You can print legal stamps, all
right? Right off their website,
right out of your printer,
right onto your envelope or onto a box.
You got a little scale if you need like a,
whatever you call that one,
the postage, I guess you can,
you can do the whole thing.
You can do everything that you can do
at the post office except waste time in
your life. All right? stamps.com
will not only save you time,
you can buy and print out,
like I just said,
the official us postage on
your computer or printer.
You can print exact postage on any other
pocket package right from your desk.
Um,
stamps.com we'll also save you money.
It's a fraction of the cost of a
postage meter. Plus you get discounts,
you can't even find it.
The post office. Um,
right now, if you use my last name
bur bur for the special offer,
you get a no risk trial plus a $110
bonus offer that includes a digital scale
and up to 55 a free dollars in postage.
All right?
Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
now, before you do anything else,
click on the radio microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are that stamps.com and
enter burpee you are are.
And um,
also I have other exciting news.
If that was an exciting
enough that you can bring to
the post office,
into your apartment,
it'd be great if you could bring
the titty bar into your apartment.
Are you sick of going there and paying
those high ATM fees for a Woman Who's not
going to bang you?
Wouldn't it be nice if somebody came and
shook their teddies right in your own
department? It. tidies.com um,
I was telling you guys how if you go
to amazon.com through my website on the
podcast page, you just click on it
and if you're going to buy something,
you just buy it. That way you
don't have to do anything else.
Once you get to amazon.com that they
kicked me back some money in 10% of the
proceeds go to the wounded warriors.
Well I got my first check
from amazon.com so I,
I can't do it today
cause they don't do that.
They don't pick up the mail tomorrow.
I get to write a nice check, um,
courtesy of you guys for taking the
time to go through bill.com go to the
podcast page and clicking
on the Amazon banner.
And I want to thank all you guys
for doing that because uh, you know,
this is really perfect
memorial day weekend to be
bringing this up to we get to
actually, uh, you know,
help out the wounded warriors project
through a buy and flowbees on amazon.com.
So I actually use it.
I'm rebuilding this cabaret data and
I'll just go on my own damn podcast,
click on that,
you know,
rebuild in the Holly 41 60 dude and uh,
I know that, that sounds impressive. It
definitely has that man great vibe to it,
doesn't it?
But I gotta tell you it's
not that difficult taking
it apart and then putting it
back together. It really
isn't that difficult. Uh,
what is difficult though is a,
I haven't got to the part where
you get to use a little measurer.
It makes sure the float is that the
right level and then adjusting the
carburetors.
But I gotta be honest with you,
I don't think that that is going to get,
is going to be that hard either.
Once you've taken something apart,
you know what I mean? I don't,
and then put it back together.
It's not as scary anymore,
which is why surgeons is so
God damn arrogant. You know,
when they cut you open and move
around you frigging ovaries,
easy your goddamn liver and then sew
you back up when you don't die. I mean,
do you really think that they think
they're buying the next round? I think,
you know, is arrogant, is professional
athletes are, I think that like,
surgeons should be twice as
fucking arrogant really to
just split the d and dunk
from the foul line.
I cut open a guy's skull,
fucking played patty cake with his brain.
Put it back together and he
can still talk. All right,
go fuck yourself, Colby. Um,
and then he steps on you.
All right, let's get back to the
podcast here. Where the hell is it?
What's the rest of this stuff here? Uh,
oh my God. Here's one for you guys. Uh,
my boyfriend wants to have his
foreskin restored. By the way,
how fresh and new are these,
uh, these emails here?
Just because it's coming from the female
perspective. I love this shit. All right.
Not Saying I don't want guys to email him,
but I,
I would like to have a nice balance here.
I already say enough shit.
Trash and women. So it helps if women
come in trash and guys, because, uh,
I, you know, it'll, it'll be a
nice balance here. All right.
My boyfriend wants to have his
for skin restored. Dear bill,
I wanted to get your take on the situation
I'm in with my current boyfriend. Uh,
I'm a girl. All right. A few weeks ago,
my boyfriend of two years told me that
he's become totally upset that he and
wants to restore his for skin via
taping and stretching methods.
What,
and basically why he wants to do this
is because everybody, they say that, um,
intercourse you, you lose like, I don't
know, some percentage of sensitivity
when you have, you're
forced skin removed. And um,
okay.
All I can say is no guy can tell the
difference whether he has a four skin or
whether he doesn't.
Because unless you got laid when
you were fucking six weeks old,
you don't know what you're
gaining of what you're missing.
So I don't understand why you would do
this. So t by restore his force can,
via taping and stretching
methods. She goes, I know, I know.
It makes me want to throw up just
thinking about it. I want him to tell him,
I think he's out of his mind. Uh, but
I don't want to hurt his feelings.
The thing is,
I'm totally grossed out by the idea
of for skin penises are gross enough
already. There's no need to make
it even grosser. Uh, you know,
what am I the only guy that
totally agrees with that?
Is there anything more fucking disgusting?
Then I'll fucking flacid
for skin covered Dick.
I didn't know what it looks like.
It looks like I got a fucking,
I don't know what it looks like.
Okay.
I, it's just this fucking disgusting.
I don't even have like a reference.
Looks like an Elephant Dick.
I get, I don't even know
what to say. It's just gross.
It's fucking disgusting. Um, she goes,
obviously I can't tell him how I feel.
He's clearly having a
really hard time with this.
He tells me that he feels violated
and disfigured. This guy's a pussy,
this throat, this throw this
guy into the fucking pussy, Ben,
and get on with your life.
He also claims that for skins has a
lot of advantage for both partners,
but it's hard for me to totally buy that
considering the fact I have slept with
a couple uncircumcised guy and I
didn't notice any extra pleasure.
Although I did use a condom
with both guys. Yeah,
he's full of Shit. He's full of Shit.
It may be more pleasure for him.
I don't know what I mean.
I think it's amazing that women
will put a dick in their mouths.
You know the at least you can do is
try and tidy up down there. You know?
How about having fucking empathy?
I've asked you this, discuss. It's
just fucking extra skin. Yeah.
Nothing more sexier than
extra skin. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like your Dick used to be
obese and then lost a ton of weight,
but didn't have enough money to have
that surgery. They get rid of the extra.
Ah, it's gross. There's
another two paragraphs,
people just just preparing you for
another two paragraphs of having an
uncircumcised stretch taped
dick in your head. Anyway,
I think it's absolutely disgusting and
totally weird that he wants to do this
and I'm starting to get really turned off
by the idea of sleeping with him while
he's stretching out his force.
Good.
He told me he's going to
tape it to an elastic strap,
which is going to tie around his leg.
I know.
What the fuck is he just coming
up with this shit on his own?
Yeah.
I told him that he should see a
doctor before he starts to do this,
but he doesn't want,
but he doesn't think that doctors know
much about this sort of thing. Oh,
so he's just going to take it in his
own hands. Congratulations sweetheart.
You're dating a fucking moron.
Yeah,
that, come on. This is
the father. You children.
Okay.
Coming up with, you know,
taking an erector set to his
fucking Dick. It was this,
do I have to finish reading this?
Yeah.
I'm thinking of breaking it off
with them really. Course you are.
I thought he was a normal guy,
but I had no idea he had all this freaky
shit going on underneath the surface.
Anyways.
What do you think about all of this?
You got to go ll cool j.
You just got to do any of that.
You're stretching out your fucking
Dick. I know. I said I'd be true.
You're stretching out your fucking Dick.
So I'm leaving you go fuck yourself.
It's over. Yeah. Fucking gross.
Anyway,
what do you think all this is my justified
dumping him away or would that make
me an insensitive comment? No, it
would make you as strong person.
All right.
Go with your gut on this one.
Okay.
This guy is trying to to
do the impossible, like,
uh, like he said, fucking
scientist in that Michael J.
Fox movie back to the future.
Okay.
He's basically,
you know,
doing the Delorean bullshit with his Dick
and he doesn't want to go see a doctor.
Any doctor would tell them,
you can't do that.
Yeah,
you'll be funny. That was if you dumped
this guy right, and it actually works.
And then he starts screaming
like Billy Mays on TV with his,
his Dick Stretcher and
he sells it for 1995.
It makes a zillion dollar. I'm just
playing devil's advocate here. You know
there's a 99% chance you're
doing the right thing,
but there is a 1% chance you
could be walking away from a,
a potential millionaire.
Cause I gotta be honest with you if,
if that guy actually pulls this off,
no pun intended, he pulls this off.
Okay.
And he's able to do it with some
household material and then he,
you know, Pete, they already make
millions of dollars with those,
those pills that say they're
going to make your Dick Bigger,
which we all know it doesn't
work because of it fucking work.
That would be an international story.
And um,
and then it still wouldn't work because
then what would happen was everybody
would take big dick pills,
even guys with big dicks because they
don't want everybody else catching up with
them.
So then having a little dick would
then be like having a six inch dick as
opposed to a three inch,
four inch Dick. Right.
It's a math workout on that or get bumped
up. You've got to six, seven inch Dick.
You just, he just regular, no,
you don't actually, not regularly.
You'd have a little Dick.
Okay,
so if this guy actually
fucking is able to pull this,
that doesn't even make sense.
He's going, he, if he
thought he was disfigured,
now wait till he tries to fucking do this.
I mean his dick is going to look like,
you know when those people put that shit,
their ear lobes,
they put those fucking, um,
those circles circular things.
You could shoot a God damn fucking bow
and Arrow through somebody's ear low,
but not drawing any blood.
He's going to do that to his deck,
except he's not going to have that
thing in there and it's just going to be
hanging. Ah, right bill. We
got it. It's disgusting. All
right. Overrated. Underrated,
underrated.
A steakhouse dinner with your bullies.
There's nothing better than stuffing
your fat face with your friends devouring
menu. Philemon, yawn,
prime rib and porterhouse and leaving
nothing on your plate at the end.
Recently my two buddies and I went to
Morton steak house and we spent a 115
bucks despite having a hundred dollar gift
card. We each got our own stakes side,
shrimp cocktails to start and
drinks to keep us twisted.
We ate like royal royalty despite
being low level pieces of shit.
He cannot even,
we could not have been that
gluttonous with the ladies.
Why not?
No offense to any wives or girlfriends,
but nothing beats pigging out on quality
food and not giving a shit about how
you look in the process.
You and your girl just can't do
that sort of steakhouse thing,
but you can do it with your
boys. Abso-Fucking-Lutely
uh, you know what dude?
You sound like a chick. You're not
going to pick out in front of you girl.
Yeah.
You know what?
Come see me in San Jose when
fucking Peretti opens up for me.
She actually talks about eating. A lot of
women don't want to fucking throw down.
Yeah.
All right. But I know what you mean.
I thought just to hang out with guys,
it just makes you feel like you're running
your own corporation when you have a
steak dinner with, with, with just
hanging out with the guys, right.
It's smoking a cigar.
I get drinking a scotch and everybody
feels like they're fucking, you know,
HD Buttercup, Shea, um,
overrated fake tits.
They're too stiff. The, uh,
they look silly to me and
uncomfortable for her.
I don't know why women keep doing
this. It isn't better. Thank you.
That's one of the truest things
ever. You, they're fucking,
they're horrific and they don't feel good.
And I think natural
titties look better always,
regardless of the size. It's just,
it's just not that big a deal.
It really is that you would do that,
that you would take a bag of chemicals
and have it inserted into your body.
It's just fucking insane. I think, uh,
it was a bad idea and I think
it's over fake titties. It's,
it's like bell bottoms. It's over.
All right. Let's just let it go.
It was a bad idea. Uh,
underrated. The natural boob,
both Gigli and ECO friendly.
Absolutely. Um, all right.
That's the podcast for this week.
I think I hit everything I had to talk
about except a, I guess, game fly.com.
I didn't bring that up. All
you video gamers out there,
you guys seen the new, uh,
grand theft auto that's coming up. Well,
why don't you go to fucking game fly.com.
Why am I cursing?
Why don't you go to game fly.com?
Yeah.
Huh? Why don't shift? Where the hell is
it? Where the hell it man? Grades. Stabs,
duck advertising
schedule. Here we go. Stay
game.
fly.com everybody go to game
fly.com/burr and you'll immediately,
you get a 50 day free trial to
all my listeners. All right.
You'll have access to 8,000
video games at your fingertips.
It can be delivered to your
door or straight to your PC,
www.gainfly.com/birth 15 days after 15
days of playing a 8,000 video games.
If that's even possible. You can
be like, yeah, you know what?
I don't want it go to health.
Why wouldn't you do that?
Huh?
You know why? Because you self
sabotage and you have to stop in.
It begins today with gamefly.com/
[inaudible] all right.
That's the podcast for this week.
MMM.
Congratulations to everybody who's
team who won in the playoffs and a my
condolences even to the Rangers, man,
I just break you guys balls. Okay?
MMM.
That's it. That's the podcast. Let's
go. Celtics fucked the Miami heat a,
it's going to crush me to see the spurs
win the championship again this year
because I always felt Tim Dunkin
should have been a Celtic. He was,
he's the perfect Celtic
fundamentally sound, not flashy.
The Anti Showtime Lakers.
It's what made the Celtics
Lakers rivalry so great.
They were both awesome teams who did it
two different ways and we were always
the, uh, we're going to bore you to
death and still score 108 points.
That's how we always were.
And uh, ah, I forget what,
there was some bullshit that
happened that year on the lottery.
We had like two lottery balls and
we still didn't fucking get them.
I don't know who the fuck we
want to aunt wound up with,
like Joe Barry Carroll or some bullshit.
So it kills me. And uh, you know what?
It's a, you know what I think
you think maybe San Antonio,
we'll finally get some fucking respect.
If they win it again,
would this be Tim Duncan's fourth
or fifth title? I can't remember.
He wanted 99.
Then they want to like oh
four then they want to like,
they want like every other year
for a couple of years. I have no,
I gotta look that up.
I got no idea and I should know that ship.
He was want at least three Oh bill, shut
the fuck up. All right. Go Fuck Yourself.
So I'll talk to you next week.